car qu'ils savaient que la gare h&m a ri
et mégane continue et c'est le daily
mail qui nous balance la formation le
daily mail il faut remettre en
perspective c'est pas le times 1 c'est
un tabloïd néanmoins fils et revoici
locale sans voici le ko closer mais
un faisceau d'indicés qui est en train
de se regrouper souvenez-vous j'étais
venu en parler ici même au mois d'avril
oui il était parti pour la r où il se
rendait aux invictus biais mais ils ont
profité du vol privé pour faire un
détour par londres où ils ont été
introduits auprès d'élisabeth deux
nouveaux ces finales de la saison devant
mesure on sait maintenant que ils ont
demandé à voir et il avait 2 et plus
personnellement le staff de buckingham
palace parce que il comptait obtenir des
autorisations pour le tournage valls en
vue des quatre jours du jubilé qui était
en train de se profiler on sait très
bien maintenant que cette rencontre
s'est très mal passé et que d'emblée
sort edward yu le secrétaire particulier
de la reine et son staff ont dit les
petits amis même pas en rêve vous
obtiendrez le minimum d'accréditation
possible ne comptez pas sur nous pour
vous fournir de la matière et à partir
de ce moment là on sait maintenant que
netflix a commencé à réorienter à re
scénariser son documentaire parce qu'il
fait sont dit on n'a vraiment en manque
de matière se mesure et c'était surfer
sur la vague royal donc on apprend que
ce qui devait être un long documentaire
de plus ou moins 90 minutes ja d'être
redit les en une série de petites
séquences qui durait approximativement
25 30 minutes et dans lequel ben ça va
être un peu une télé réalité mais non on
va suivre alors c'est le 2e stone et son
make up oui non pas intégré à la nation
pas là car la convention mais on essaie
de cartonner on fait alors à bientôt
donner oui mais pas davantage suivre à
pied mais lyon dans leur quotidien
mainichi tôt vous savez cette magnifique
propriété qu'ils ont acheté plus gay
friendly à leur égard a dû 10 chambres
le psy l'intérieur piscine extérieure
que ce que court de tennis ça c'est
vraiment la grille était à l'américaine
et alors ce que l'on sait déjà que c'est
que durant ces quatre jours de jubiler
d'elisabeth deux états il était en mode
tournage maintenant avantage en mode
saas et résignation d'elizabeth ii et je
ne sais pas si vous avez entendu
l'information mais s'amusent à nous
montrer de la couronne le jeudi jour de
la le jour le plus important le jour de
la parade militaire qui marque vraiment
officiellement le jour de la reine et de
touba rippingtons featuring ils arrivent
en retard
pourquoi n'at-il en retard parce que eh
bien il fallait tourner les séquences
pour netflix allait elle a débarqué avec
son maquilleur avec son coiffeur avec
son équipe est revenue à plusieurs
reprises oui n'est ce pas le travail à
plusieurs reprises tourné des séquences
aussi que ce qui fait qu'ils sont
arrivés en retard pourquoi ne sont ils
pas présent le samedi mais samedi on
attendait là il ya une fan phrase
bergen
mais samedi c'est le fameux concert vous
avez qui a réuni 1 million de personnes
sur le moule ils sont attendus dans les
guest au sein de cette royale box la
royal box c'est les tribunes où les
windsor ont pris place rires je suis là
dans le public je cherche avec mes
petites jumelles
ouais j'ai beau regarder je ne les
trouve jamais pourquoi est d'abord que
tout simplement ils sont en tournage
avec netflix en qui ils ont décidé de
suivre la retransmission ses montres les
yeux des locaux du pôle
c'est le premier à le dire go go avec a
été avec une couronne
il était surtout une première à léon les
ans ils foutent rien et que c'est
maintenant qu'il
n'arrive pas à voir un poke d'aubade à
des flics c'est profondément cynique de
ne rien on peut être 100 millions de
dollars il serait prêt à toucher 100
millions de dollars pour ce fameux
documentaire ils en ont touché 33 jusque
maintenant il y en a tant fait que le
tournage est plus loin pour qu'il touche
les
72 1 millions de dollars pour coucher
avec jean-michel mais alors tu penses
que tu es ce que tu confirmes l'anecdote
est vrai qu'ils ont voulu filmer la
rencontre entre la petite et la reine
d'angleterre c'est sa voix qui me choque
le plus c'est finalement cette séquence
de vie qui est un peu un teint mais
familial et qu'ils aient voulu affirmer
que les abbés teddy nos oreilles c'est
pas qu'ils ont voulu la filmer c'est en
effet ils ont présenté donc
officiellement la petite amie à la reine
elle n'avait jamais été présenté et ils
ont demandé pour venir avec photographie
alors vraiment rien a dit il en est hors
d'eau subsistent arrêter là parce que là
je n'ai plus pu entendre cette année
garon tamedia non mais tu avais gars
c'est pas possible on a ramené hamburger
au pays du royaume uni ça